Devin Reeve: It’s interesting how projects
come to us.
My business partner (Larry Layfield) and I
have a company called InnoVate Productions.
We work as a creative development and producing
team, but we also work as a line producer
and a UPM team (Unit Production Manager).
So for this project, they reached out to us.
They needed a line producer, someone to manage
this whole team for what we’re trying to
do.
And then other times people send us scripts
and we develop our own content and we produce
it and develop it, raise the funding and do
it ourselves.
We have another film going on right now that
is actually filming, while we are filming
this (ROCK IN A HARD PLACE) that a friend
of mine was directing.
He had another producer on it.
He asked ‘Would you
come in with your company and take over the
production for me?”
And we were like “Absolutely,” so we
did that.
It’s another reason why we’re tired.
So we we’re hired, we partnered up with
people to create our own content and put things
out there.
We do everything from music videos to commercials
to films.
We have a music video coming up with Holly
Holm who beat Ronda Rousey in February and
we’re actually doing a commercial with Ronda
(it was already set in place before she got
beat) for an energy company that she has a
contract with.
So lots of fun things coming our way.
We developed a Halloween special that right
now is in development that is in a really
good position to come out next year, so we’re
kind of moving forward, whether we create
it yourself of people hire us, we just like
to keep working.
Film Courage: Devin, you say you’ve been
doing this 15 years?
Devin: Yeah, I’ve been acting since I
was a child (since I was 10) and I’ve been
producing since….first film I produced was
2005.
10 years.
Film Courage: And so in the beginning, in
2005.
Did you already have inroads through the acting
where you could reach out to people or was
there a website or some place where you went
to look for people looking for line producers?
Devin: When I started, when I said “I
want to produce my own stuff,” very shortly
after that I realized no one is just calling
you to produce.
No one’s calling to say, “Do you want
to produce a film with me?”
Because if they are, they’re calling you
to produce it because they need money.
So part of a producer’s job is to raise
funding for it, if I’m the executive producers.
So I taught myself to line produce.
I went and bought Movie Magic Budgeting.
I was already good with managing money and
managing people.
I said “Oh, that’s not that bad.”
So the first thing I lined produced was a
short film, that was a $50,000 short film.
Pretty good budget for a short film.
Just started from there and then I think the
next thing I did was a feature film that was
like $200,000 and slowly just worked my way
up, so by making that transition, to line
producing it opened up other doors for people
to actually start calling, it opened up
doors for producing and for acting, for line
producing and it was a good move for myself
because I was doing really well and I hit
a brick wall.
And I was like, “Oh man, what did my manager
say when I hit a certain age I hit a brick
wall and then after a couple years you will
kind of gain your momentum again” and she
was just dead on.
And that’s kind of what I did in my spare
time and now I’m lucky to be able to have
those different skills to help you stay busy
all the time.
Question: Do you have any advice on finding
a movie producer?